- What's up, I'm Ryan Beck
and I'm at Clusterfest
and I'm gonna do
everything in my power
to get Stephan Jenkins
from Third Eye Blind
to sing to my dog.
(laughing)
Look, I'm doing it.
- This is his hair.
Ryan.
- Yeah?
- We got a boom,
it's out of frame.
- Yeah.
- We got a puppy.
Let's make some basic cable.
- It'll be on the internet.
I'm Ryan Beck, I'm
here at Clusterfest
with one of my all time
favorite musicians,
Stephan Jenkins of
Third Eye Blind.
- Is that true?
- It's true, man.
It's the first CD I ever bought.
- Really? You didn't
say that before we met.
- Well I didn't wanna tell
you because I felt like it--
- It's important
not to talk it out.
- Yeah.
- Well anyway, this is Bruce.
- Bruce, she's a sweet girl.
- She is.
- And she is a rescue dog.
- She is a Rocket Dog
rescue, and when I got her,
she had mange, she had worms.
She had an ear infection.
She was malnutritioned.
She was just beat to shit.
Well, 'cause I wanted a
boy, but girls are better
'cause when you
stroke their belly,
there's not all that
annoying dick in the way.
- That's true.
My dog's a girl, and
she's also a rescue,
and, uh, I think I have
a picture here, some,
oh yeah, here we go.
- Oh wow.
- This enormous--
- That's a big picture.
- This is it right here.
My dog.
- Lily's so cute,
she looks fake.
- She's home alone right now,
and all she has is my girlfriend
and my girlfriend's parents
and her sister and
some dog walkers
and some other family
friends with her.
- It's like abuse.
- I know.
And so, I know she's
really missing me,
and probably feels really alone.
- She doesn't give a damn.
- No, man, come on.
- She's your dog.
- I don't have any
musical talent.
I can't play any instruments,
and people generally
just don't respect me.
So, uh, I wrote this
song from the perspective
of my dog--
- Lily's Ballad.
- Yeah, it's her song that
she feels when she's alone.
And you want me to sing it?
-I would love for you to sing i.
Thing is, I'm like high on anti.
Because I think I got bronchiti.
Are you on, I'm allergic to amo.
I don't really know what amoxic.
It's the pink one.
So, I think it goes like this.
- That's it?
Is there one more page?
- That's it.
- I want to have something
that rhymes with, like,
you know, "Come on, let's play."
♪ Your name is Bruce
♪ It doesn't matter if you're
straight or you're gay ♪
♪ Ta da
- "Ta da."
(laughing)
That was incredible.
- That's a really great song.
- Thanks, man.
- Yeah.
- You can play it
later if you want.
- I've got it, it's
all locked in here.
Is your dog a rescue?
- My dog is a rescue.
- That's great.
Here's the thing.
- Yeah?
- We both have these, like,
like, lovely,
happy, healthy dogs
and they're both rescues.
It's really great and easy
and karmically lovely to
get a rescue dog.
There will be shit
all over your kitchen
for longer than you
think that you can stand,
but you'd be amazed at
what you can put up with
when you cuddle with them.
- That's the journey.
Shit in your kitchen.
- Yeah.
- Folks, I'm Ryan Beck.
That's Stephan Jenkins.
We sang the song,
thanks for watching.
(upbeat music)